hey everyone eric here just wanted to
give a quick intro
before the actual video begins
i know this is kind of weird but um a
couple weeks ago
i had a chess lesson with a friend
um was not live streamed but um it was
just a zoom call
and it was a friend who recently caught
the the chess bug
has gotten really into chess playing a
lot of games online
and um in this video we go over some of
his games we
review some of the common mistakes that
he made
we talk about how to how to further
improvement how to get better
i think a lot of what we talked about
will hopefully be beneficial
to the the newer players watching
so what i'll do is i will timestamp the
moments in the video
where we we analyze the games the
specific teams that we
cover towards the end of the video we go
over
more specific opening strategy from the
white side
so really hope you guys enjoy this for
those of you that
have questions leave them below in the
comments and
also let me know if you want to see more
content like this
so without further ado hope you enjoy
the video um
but it was only recently that i like got
an account online and started playing
him and then i started playing other
friends
and i i'm like frankly i'm
kind of addicted to it like i it's
addicting
yeah so um but yeah it's fun to like
i think i'm i'm creeping up into like
you know knowing what not to do and what
to do
a little more more and more each day but
i still have like
blunders and stuff you know definitely
some some flaws yeah i mean
no i could definitely see based on your
games that you have
you have much better understanding than
just a complete beginner
so yeah i got the sense you you
definitely have had some like experience
under your belt
which is good there was one there was
one recently that i
i hope you didn't look at that i lost
like really quickly
i so i looked at it i looked at the two
recent games that you played against
wild champion
oh okay yeah so the one the most recent
one is the one that
i think there was one point where i
messed up or like i didn't have it set
up right should i go to
that game also right now yeah so i um i
just
invited you to it's called a study
oh okay if you check like in the upper
right hand corner
if you're on lee chess it says you're on
the gateway
oh i see yeah yeah um i sent you a link
to it's like a shared analysis board oh
awesome yeah i was wondering how wait so
is this my game
with him uh yeah so
maybe first of all i can explain the
interface but it should be synced up too
so do you see the starting position dude
that is so cool
yeah okay yeah this is how i give all my
my lessons
so everything should be synced and like
if if i play a move
then you should see it and if you play a
move i should see it
oh but you can also wait so i can move
if i want so try moving yeah
well my my um oh i see
so that was my first move right right
okay so we're all synced up
that should be good yeah yeah and if you
look
on the left side
um you'll see like it says four chapters
i don't know
let's see that oh i have it on a
different plate i have it on the
like bottom right of the board
chapters oh oh yeah you it might be uh
might be moved around
but um every chapter is a different game
that you played
so i brought in the game
um so it's a nice way to like kind of
keep things organized and
wow that is so cool did it just sync up
with
chess.com or uh so that like
there's a way that i'm able to bring in
um i basically copy the game
and notation i'd import it
uh into this um okay so
chess.com has like a similar feature
but it's not as user friendly and it
doesn't save
everything yeah so with this like
whatever we go over like everything will
be saved if you want everyone to like go
back and
review what you did wow this is this is
awesome okay
cool yeah yeah and then the great thing
is like it's all free too like
this is all open source and there's no
like
um there's no premium version you just
have access to
all the features awesome um
so yeah i thought we could start like we
can like go through your games and see
what went well and what what kind of
went terribly wrong
sure yeah of course i'd love to i'd love
to see
yeah uh maybe we can start with uh the
wild champion
[Music]
i think this was this was the second
most recent game that you played against
yeah yeah because i was a lower rate
uh rating when i played them i think i
don't know
anyway so okay if this move right here
that's what i
of played right the you were black
oh okay so we'll look from your
perspective
and like have you so it seems like
you've learned a lot from just playing
games have you formally
like studied like books or you've
watched videos or
like basically only videos and what he
what this guy will he he's told me a lot
like he will
tell me oh that was that was a huge
blunder and that you basically were done
after that
or stuff like you know at the very
beginning
don't do this don't do that like i
remember at one point i was like
really aggressively attacking just
because i thought that's
what i was supposed to do and he was
like yeah you're bringing your queen out
early
and you know it's not really people
don't really do that unless you know
what you're doing which
which i didn't so um yes so i
i kind of like just from videos and
stuff like trying to set up
control of the center i guess is what
i've been trying to do lately
yeah like yeah and in the beginning of
the game there's certain principles that
you usually want to abide by
of course there's always exceptions but
um yeah yeah
it seems like at least based on the way
you played this game
and then based on the way you played the
the game the next game against him or
even the game against me
you you've you followed like a lot more
principles in the later games uh-huh
yeah
um but yeah like in general so you know
like the three stages of a chess game is
usually the opening middle game and end
game
yeah um and each stage kind of requires
different
different strategies different things to
consider
and and to look for um but yeah like as
you mentioned in the opening like you
really want to focus on central control
yeah and
developing your your knights and bishops
um and then also getting your king safe
yeah yeah so i think this game
was it was a great example of of like
what not to do
even even though you like you you played
fine like these were both fine moves
um especially this move like you you
made sure that uh
your knight's not like pinned to your
your king
yeah i think i i think i did that i mean
the other thing that
i have been doing i think or that i was
doing when someone does that
um and sort of pins the knight down
is doing um pawn
a6 oh sure um
but i don't know that that just opens up
that corner and now i
now i can't really castle on that side
you know what i mean
yeah um or or maybe maybe that's not
this is a situation like this is a type
of situation you'll encounter
a lot of times like early in the game
when the bishop comes here
it can happen on the other side too if
you have a knight do it
on the other side it's something that
you do to your opponent as well
yeah um so this move is always something
to consider
in this case it's actually not a bad
move okay you're not really weakening
yourself
okay if white takes your knight you can
take back
and um there's this notion um
in chess it's called double pawns if you
have two pawns in the same file
yeah it's sometimes considered weak
where
the pawns can't defend each other in
this case it's not so weak because it's
hard for white to actually exploit
these pawns and white traded off the
only developed piece
right well they could they could exploit
it later maybe right
potentially yeah but for the time being
like you you can
you can kind of do your own thing focus
on and developing your king side
very likely you'll end up casting this
way okay um
and like the game could continue right
uh like this like why could castle
and one so one of the mistakes i've seen
you make
maybe in all of the games that i looked
at was not being as
active with your bishops very often
you would play a move like pawn e6 yeah
which would open up one bishop but it
would block in another vision
yeah yeah um so in general like
in the beginning of the game you want to
be as nice as possible to your
your bishops like both of them yeah so
the best approach here would be to do
something like bishop
to g4 and then later play e6 so
you make both bishops happy so so what
would i do
in that case if i played uh
g4 and he played h3
yeah good question so here um
are you familiar with what a pin is
yeah so the the right yeah that's a pin
right so the bishop is pinning the
knight to the queen
yeah because so that knight can't move
exactly
so you you would much rather maintain
the pin
uh the the move here probably the best
move is bishop h5
and then the other thing is what about g
and if they play g4
yeah so yeah there's always this uh kind
of this
scenario where actually here you you
have a couple
options the safest move and the
the simplest move is just bishop bishop
goes back to g6 right
you save your bishop you're you're
completely solid
and the fact that white advances the
pawns especially in front of the king
it creates opportunities later for the
king to be a bit more weak
yeah has a bit less defense and even
like in the very near future you can
consider playing h5
you try and trade off the pawn get your
rook into play
um i think this is kind of how i ended
up
beating you was your king got weak
because it didn't have shelter and then
the position opened up
well you did something just crazy at the
beginning that i was
that i just like didn't see at all like
i don't even know if you did it again i
don't think i would be able to
i wouldn't i wouldn't know how to
because i remember your queen
we can look at it later but yeah anyway
yeah yeah yeah
i i can show you like more specific like
opening strategy
especially like so much what i did um
because it's something you can do
yourself against other players yeah yeah
um but yeah in general you you don't
want to necessarily trade so early it's
better to keep the pin
if you can't yeah um now the other
possibility in this position if you want
to go real wild is to take
which generally is not my choice
even though you get two pawns for giving
away a knight
and you maintain the pin oh yeah that's
true i know it looks good like the
king's a bit more naked
but you're down material you did lose
material
and i don't know if this is so justified
yeah yeah um
so yeah i i would play this and if white
plays g4 it's probably more harmful to
white
than it is okay um
and if white doesn't play h3 and does
something else let's say
say some sad bishop move then you
continue and
you complete development you're super
solid nothing really to worry about
and even later like maybe play this move
to like undouble your pawns
yeah honestly uh the the bishop
to pin with the knight is something that
seems like it can happen
basically in every game like there's
that opportunity to do that
in a lot of games that i've been playing
because most people i've played with
like most the people i play are sort of
at my level also and we kind of all open
the same way
similarly it's interesting it's
definitely it's definitely an
opportunity that
i i stopped doing it i stopped doing
that pin
because i just knew that they were gonna
play those pawns and
you know i guess if they haven't castled
yet then they can't castle on that side
but
i kind of just stopped doing it because
i thought
oh the other thing is like i i oh the
other reason i stopped doing it is
because
in a video i think it was uh john
bartholomew was saying
um don't don't move your bishops and
knights passed halfway
early on in the game oh interesting what
i mean yeah but i don't
i don't know that i kind of was just
like yeah maybe i should play closer to
the chest
you know yeah but then i kind of get
stuck like you're saying
before i got stuck so this is probably
one exception where it's okay to move
into your opponent's territory
yeah okay like they can't effectively
exploit your piece here
yeah okay makes sense yeah but
like this would also be a completely
fine move if you wanted to be even more
solid and then
you still go for this sure
um but if we see what happened in the
game
uh right oh right okay i actually don't
know if there's so much
to look at like beyond the first few
moves because things went downhill
really really quickly
wait this is the this is where you were
trying to be super aggressive and you
just
you kind of kamikazed and then it
just oh you know what i think he said
that i think he actually used that term
ah
yeah because you
so first of all yeah it's very important
um
like when you play chess that you think
from both perspectives you want to focus
on what you want to do
but after every move that your opponent
plays you always have to ask yourself
what does opponent want to do and with
this move they're they're attacking your
pawn which is undefended
right then i didn't defend it
yeah you you did something so you gave
white another target
and um
like even though so you are attacking
this pawn
but it's defended twice so it's not like
you're not threatening to win anything
yeah and you've ended up just losing
your like a very key center pawn
yeah and then okay you guys traded
didn't work and then you violated like
every principle with this move
really why so uh if we think about the
principles
you want to control the center you want
to develop your knights and bishops
you moved upon on the flank maybe you
had some genius intention with this
but i didn't i didn't believe me but i
thought that that
well now i see that it's a completely
undefended pawn for the queen
it is defended by the rook so oh sorry
yeah
no but i i think i saw that in a video
of somebody who played that
might have been the same guy same video
and he said it's always a safe move or
something or
oh dude i think this was in this might
have been in a game i watched that
he played with you once there's a video
of him playing with you
and he did that but i'm not on the same
level so i maybe i should just stop
playing that move
yeah like if you're gonna yeah
especially move your uh
your flank pawn you're like you're your
pawn you want
you really have to have a good reason
for it yeah
um sometimes it's used like if white has
this move committed
then you you're trying to attack um but
there's bigger
bigger issues to address with your king
and your minor pieces still
not yeah not being true on their best
squares
um so yeah we don't have to look at this
game
anymore yeah you don't want to i
wouldn't do
much of this stuff today i don't know
for sure and like what happened in the
game i i think you you just wanted to
bring your rook out but you allowed i
think
it takes great so just like a better
approach
is com like bring out your bishop to a
central square bring out your nightmares
castle
and like you lost upon but you're still
fighting yeah yeah and you're not
self-destructing more
most importantly um
right yeah so
like this sort of game i think there's a
few a few like
lessons to take away and in general like
this is what your goal should be
especially when you have
uh like bad losses is that you take away
at least like one or two things
that you can apply in the future um
so so the bishop that i played um to d7
you said that was okay but you rather
would have played
on to a6 or yeah yeah if if
you're doing this so early then yeah
this would have been completely fine for
you
okay cool um and then of course like be
a bit safer
like in a position like this uh i think
the best move is just to develop your
knight and defend the pawn
yeah very multi-purpose and control the
center
so okay cool anyway we can uh
probably move on from this game yeah
let's go to a different one
um so i have the
i do have the next game that you played
against him which was much much
higher quality on your part yeah
we can we can look at that um now
there's a few other
like few more kind of improvements
of course like based on what i said
about the previous game
um i think i already addressed this but
like this move
it's it's making your bishop sad right
yeah
yeah so what would be a like a better
move
to be nice to this bishop
i would probably just move the
move the other night yeah moving another
line is fine
yeah let's say black copy
um then i might move the bishop
but i i don't want to because you've the
fork that happened in our game right
you remember that at the beginning yeah
um
now this this is slightly different and
there's there's really no danger yet for
you
also you're white okay so right so if i
played there would that be bad i mean
so is that this this looks almost good
because yeah you're controlling the
center you're defending the pawn
but there's a big problem with this move
is that you're blocking in
your center pawn which in turn is
blocking in your bishop
so it's going to make you hard to
actually complete
development so then so then e2 or c4
would be
more yeah and actually c4 is
um c4 or b5 are actually the two more
active moves
okay um now
like we could go into more detail and i
can show you maybe something even more
specific but like in general
your your bishop is best
or is like happiest on the square
because it's like the most centralized
it doesn't block your pawn
you want to do this next you want to do
this eventually
you're also aimed at this pawn which
could be like one of the weak points in
black's position
and even like i can we can imagine let's
say black plays this move yeah
already you have a very strong move to
essentially
win material yeah which i want you to
find
okay um
is it uh is it the pawn
d2 d4 no that's not it
so that's actually not a bad move that
um
it's well supported by the knight and
queen it pressures the center
but yeah look at this pawn and try to
figure out yeah
oh look at that pawn how to attack it
uh is it um well i could attack it with
the bishop or the knight but the knight
would take a couple turns right
well it's so you mentioned bishop the
bishop is already
like aiming at the pawn yeah but then
they'll just
take it with the king right right so the
pawn is defended once
and attacked once so actually in order
to win it you have to attack another
time
oh so i can move my knight to g5 and
then attack at the next turn
exactly and okay yeah this is what we
call a threat
where you you have you now have two
attackers
black only has one defender the king is
actually one of the worst defenders in
chess because it's
it's just yeah it's vulnerable right um
and if black does nothing like let's say
black plays this
then you just take the pawn with the
knight
yeah your bishop supports the knight and
you like
on top of all this you're forking the
queen and rook
yeah wait can you go back a couple moves
yes
okay right there yeah um yeah i'm just
gonna take a picture of it and
you you should know like all of this is
being like all the moves that we're
looking at
are being saved yeah in this study
so it should be on the right side for
you
um like the notation so
like there's different sub variations
yeah
so like the main line is what happened
in your game
right but the sub variation which
we were just looking at this move knight
c3 um
it's all being saved you sometimes if
you want to go back later you have to
like
look down in the sub variations to find
what
we're looking at but so okay
i have a question yep i think we talked
about this a little in the chat but
yeah in this position so
i i might tend to avoid that
because um
i might tend to avoid that because i
wouldn't want to touch my knight twice
in the first
whatever four moves or something right
you know what i mean yeah in general
that that is
that's true that you should avoid moving
the same piece twice
here it's justified because you're
making a threat which
can't easily be stopped yeah
okay all right yeah cool and then you
take with the knight and it can't take
back with the king
so depending what black does like
there's no good way to defend
the pawn without losing something like
if queen e7
there's two defenders but they're the
most important pieces and then you just
take anyway
and black doesn't give away the queen um
the best move here is probably bishop e6
which does save the pawn but it creates
a situation where there's two attackers
and only one defender and then
wow okay then you can take it probably
doesn't matter too much what you take
with
say you take with the bishop and then
you you end up winning a pawn
so and the then the queen is and the
queen's attacked
and you can do that but you can trade
down
like next move when the queen moves you
can just trade off your knight and um
yeah yeah you want a pawn so right
okay cool um yeah so in general like you
want to be aware
of of weak points in your opponent's
position
yeah of things so usually a weak point
is something that's
undefended or
or not so well defended and easy to
attack
yeah like the f7 pawn it's already
attacked once and you can attack it
again
so it's considered a weak point
um okay cool so something to keep in
mind
yeah yeah so what you did in this game
when you played d3 you're depriving
yourself
of of having an active bishop rather
bishop's just going to be sad for a long
time and not be
not be on the nice diagonal yeah um
and your opponents your opponent did
what you should have done was develop
the bishop and then later play d6
yeah oh i see
why did i do that
yeah it's another move which i mean
sometimes it makes sense
but uh yeah probably better to focus on
just completing development of the minor
pieces
however so in this game you didn't
really make any blunders
until much later right you just made
kind of small mistakes
like that d3 and c3 these were kind of
passive moves
and it allowed your opponent to kind of
build up a pleasant position yeah
because then i can't i mean i can move i
guess i can move the other bishop right
yes and you you did move the bishop here
right what do you think of this this
like scenario here where the
queen can't take bishop yeah it's
interesting uh the thing is black
black can easily defend and black
actually play the move
saving the queen and making your bishop
move again
um but it wasn't really
it wasn't harming you too much you just
moved back okay
and uh the game continued so i'm not
sure who it benefited but
at least you got your bishop out yeah
yeah um
and then next move you probably want to
bring the knight into the center which
you did
yeah this is good and you're actually
very solid
um okay this move was questionable
yeah if i were you i'd just play like
bishop e2 castle just get the king
really safe
and you're actually like even though
you're a little bit passive like black
has better central control
right it's it's hard to crack you
because everything in your position is
defended you don't really have any weak
points
um from his point right
yeah it's hard for for black to attack
anything
yeah where you would have trouble
defending um
when you play this it creates some
opportunities i know
like you're actually trying to fork
you're trying to do what what i did to
you in our game was uh get a pawn here
and fork the knight in bishop
yeah maybe maybe i was anyway go ahead
yeah um but it does allow
so the drawback of playing this move is
you're kind of giving up control over
this square
yeah which i know it maybe it doesn't
seem like such a
hugely relevant point um but like later
on
black had al always had good control
over the square with multiple pieces
that's true yeah and your pawn served a
good purpose of restricting
i think what i was thinking is
of what would trade in the future with
this so can i can i move some pieces too
just show you okay this is what i
thought i think i thought you'd say
take you take
but he wouldn't do that and then i have
i don't know i guess that i don't know
that's probably what i was thinking and
then he wouldn't take with the bishop
you know
because then i would just take oh yeah
yeah you're like you're still defended
in this position
yeah um but you didn't really achieve
so much with this trade okay gotcha
um okay yeah you can go back and
actually like a better so if you wanted
to
let's imagine you play this castle
say you castle and let's say black plays
some
some move like queen d7
um this is a point where we're you're
kind of done with the opening
and you're enjoying the middle game
we're like your pieces are developed
you're castled and then the question is
what to do next
um and this is where sometimes you
you can't rely so much on general
principles you you really have to think
um think about what's going on position
what you can potentially attack how you
can further improve your pieces
yeah and just one thing i was going to
suggest here
uh because this move still doesn't
really achieve much but another pawn
move which is
is actually nice for you is this move
pawn b4
where you um okay your pawns are kind of
uh i don't know they're in this weird
shape but they're they're very well
supported
and you kick the bishop while kind of
gaining some territory on the queen side
yeah but can he just take with the
bishop and then i take with pawn
and then he takes with knight and then
he's
and then he's um
yeah but what did you win
oh bishop yeah so so the bishop is more
about like black doesn't want to
sacrifice the bishop for
yeah for two pawns okay um
and we'll see this a lot in chess where
like pawns can be used
as like a strong attacking pieces
because the opponent doesn't necessarily
want to
sacrifice her their knights are bishops
for them yeah
uh in this case more likely is bishop b6
i'll just show you like a nice uh tactic
like nice sort of trap that black can
fall into
because you can continue expanding you
can play this move a4
um and you have a very simple
idea let's let's say black plays like a
normal looking move
how can you win the bishop essentially
just win material
um
does it do i move oh that's not
that won't work
i i guess the pawn right which pawn
oh a a4 to a5 yeah
yeah very nice and this is what we call
uh just
trapping where the bishop is deprived of
squares like your pawns are actually
working really well together
oh okay um i've never thought of that i
honestly i don't really look like except
for that last game i guess i haven't
really been looking on the
the wing as they called the odds outside
the wing right
yeah like the flank the flank i haven't
been looking at that
gotcha area honestly yeah
this maybe goes against like one
principle of uh
of trying to focus in the center but
sometimes when there's
a target especially a piece that doesn't
have so many
available squares and you can exploit it
like this
so what if he i guess yeah
no that's true so black has to either
give away like just
lose a bishop or if it takes you take
back
if knight takes you take back the rook's
always supporting the pawn as well
yeah so it's in this position black
like black should apply this thought
process of like what does white want to
do
oh it wants to trap the bishop then the
question becomes what should black do
to not lose a bishop right
um okay and yeah maybe maybe i'll i'll
ask you this what should lack do here
not to
to lose material if you know this is
coming yeah
um
maybe move
pawn to d4
so pawn d4 is interesting
actually pawn d4 is uh that that
probably works out well
i don't know maybe not because i can
still move
so it does allow this a5 yeah
but yeah i actually didn't see this um
it actually works for black because
black can now counter attack
oh and then it frees up the d4 square
so yeah you accidentally play the
brilliant move there
well well hang on a second
so wait so go back to when
when the yeah go back to there
so then
no yeah i guess so yeah and then that
would have been
if white is this and this pawn is
undefended
black can take and right and the
bishop's not gonna have a square
okay um another
another simple move i can play to defend
is just moving this pawn
one or two squares and then it just
gives the bishop
a hiding place oh i see all right
oh is that what you oh i see okay cool
yeah
this also works this just prevents white
from advancing entirely
yeah and upon supported more than enough
times
um anyway that was kind of a tangent
that it just shows some
that's okay yeah some better middle game
ideas
sure so what did i do again so you
you played c4 yeah so
um so we just looked at what happens
when
you just play like normally and then
then one potential plan for you in the
middle game
yeah um now the game continued from here
uh and you got a nice central square for
the knights
one of the biggest problems in this game
you never got your king castled
oh okay and you were you were targeted
here this bishop check
move your knight back and
uh you play a3 a3 is a good move here
so actually a3 sets up a very similar
trap to what we just saw
where um oh yeah let's imagine black
maintains the pin
how can you trap the bishop
um
well i can't i can't take the bishop
right
but i can so you can't take the bishop
but you can you can attack the bishop
and the private of all its like
available squares before
b4 yeah now black doesn't want to
sacrifice a bishop for two pawns
right say the bishop moves he moves
there and then
c5 and c5 and again this is um this is
actually a pretty typical
like pattern of uh like of pawns just
trapping a bishop
oh i guess he would be trapped then yep
yeah the bishop just doesn't
can't move here and your pawn supported
you're going to win it
one way or another okay all right
so but okay you're playing a decently
strong player so he he guaranteed saw
that and that's why he took
um yeah making sure he's not losing
anything
yeah yep okay and then the game
continued
um so i actually i liked your move here
even though maybe it's not the best move
at least you you defended against
black's threat of this
um yes i i would have done that because
i've definitely
been a victim of that many times yeah
yeah you have to be
not saying that whenever especially
whenever a knight is in your territory
you have to be
hyper aware of what the knight wants to
do yeah
and then what your weak squares are so
this this is clearly a weak square
and that's good that you didn't allow
that
now the drawback of course is you
allowed knight takes knights
and these are not the prettiest pawns
oh wait yeah yeah
so i can't remember if it's this game oh
no it was the last one
sorry go ahead the last one
so maybe a better move it's already
difficult because you're you're being
attacked like
black threatening this and and this
um you could have taken but this would
allow queen takes and then your bishops
hit
yeah so like you're on the defensive but
maybe this would be better because you
you still have the plan of
getting your king safe and your
structure is intense anyway
yeah yeah so once once you wound up with
the double puns
um and then black was still throwing
punches too
like every every move black was making
was either a threat or
a capture here your bishop's attacked
do you think uh our from what you see of
his moves is that
basically what you would or i'm sure you
would do if you would play
differently but or his basically like
maybe what the computer
would would say are accurate or book
moves or whatever
you know so what yeah they saw
how this game unfolded your opponent
played a lot of the same moves i would
play
okay yeah actually i would probably play
this first
if if i were black and then and then
later like secure a night here
but what he did like i would definitely
play this move
um and
it's it's one of these positions where
like it was easy
easier to play from the black side
because black had more opportunities
more
weaknesses to target yeah um
and like from your side like already
because like your king's in the center
it's just easier to make mistakes and is
that
because it's just because of how i
started it off basically that i blocked
in that bishop
and did the other couple things right
the mistakes you made
they're kind of known as positional
mistakes okay
where um unlike the previous game like
you didn't give away any free material
you didn't really plunder but you you
made moves which just made your position
a bit more passive
you opened up more like you allowed more
weaknesses in your position
with these pawns even with the square
and then with this move too where the
square is in black's control
and that that kind of snowballed into
more more tactical opportunities for
your opponent
yeah but that's a good sign for you
because um most of the games
that like lower level players play
are lost based on tactical blunders
not based on positional mistakes so this
is a sign you're you're like beginning
to
uh perhaps reach a better level where
you can start addressing
more positional more solo mistakes yeah
i mean i still have you know
wonders of course but yeah but if you
minimize the blunders you'll
you'll be able to put up much better
fights
and this game was definitely a good
fight um
it wasn't clear black was winning until
a bit later
um now b3 i don't know how useful this
move is
i i know it depends upon but
so what would you what would you
recommend in this position
that's a good question um i would be
most focused on getting the king and
bishop to a better square
oh okay gosh yeah um so i could maybe do
bishop
h3 castle yeah
um bishop so bishop h3 is
probably okay um
i i'm hesitant to play this move because
it's undefended
and it's aligned with what we call a
battery
but it's probably okay because whatever
if black moves at night you just take
with check
yeah and you trade so actually yeah
bishop h3 and castling would probably be
my choice
what what else would i mean again it's
like not an ideal position
but yeah say i find myself in not an
ideal position
like this in the future you know what
what would might you do
so your your first priority is uh is
king safety
and just defending against whatever
blacks threatening
actually like when black castles there's
no immediate threat
so you do have time to try and improve
your position
i would probably be more inclined to
play bishop g2
like when you castle your king will be
super safe
yeah you also defend the pawn like i'd
be aware here that
black wants to play knight d4 and attack
your pawn
so bishop here just it's more of a
precaution
yeah and then um
the the main idea of is not only
castling but later to play f4
then your mission is actually on the
nice long open dial
oh okay i see that even though it's
passive
initially it can be it can be opened up
mm-hmm
um but yeah you kind of have to play
with uh sort of defensive mindset
yeah and black can start throwing
punches here like black can play rook d8
and while all of a sudden your pawns
attacked
the battery um
if he wants to trade queens though
that's true yeah but
a pawn would be like especially this
pawn would be valuable
because it's um it's defending this pawn
so um
yeah and then you you'd probably want to
defend it
and you're still holding on like
everything in your position is defended
even though it's it's kind of ugly you
you're like you're gonna get your king
safe you're going to have this idea
it's actually not too bad
uh what happened the game was uh was
kind of bad
because you you just played one move
that doesn't really help you in
too many ways and it just gave black
free time to
to improve maybe i was thinking
i wanted to get a pawn forward
to get it to the end like i don't know
maybe
i don't know why i don't know why i did
that which is usually a very
common strategy in the end game yeah but
in the middle game there there's more
important issues
right um and you're nowhere near like
promoting a pawn
so um yeah let's see what happened with
one
aha yeah so even here like you can still
go for this idea
um but the the main thing which like
which ended up causing your downfall
was just your your king was a sitting
duck and eventually
black got the rook to the file and then
your king just had no shelter
yeah do do you castle in every single
game like personally
uh no but more more than half the time i
do
but i mean i probably should because i
don't know how to deal with it if i
don't
yeah yeah yeah like chess is a game like
it can branch out in so many different
directions right
um it'd be interesting like analysis
like statistical analysis to do
uh with just games in general but i
probably castle in
i'd say 70 to 80 of my games
but there's times where like the king is
just safe in the center
or queens are traded early and the
king's not in danger of getting mated
yeah but this is a situation where yeah
this move the bishop that's where he
said that he
said that was my worst move ah yeah i
probably agree but it's already like
very difficult because your rook's
attached yeah
and this move is coming regardless
um so i would make the argument your
worst move was actually d4
oh the very next one yeah because you're
you're still
you can still try and fight yeah
by means of defending like your bishop's
attack twice
uh so you could try rook d2 here
defending the bishop
um and um it's still a question how
black is
it's actually cracking your position
because maybe next move you you want to
defend the bishop again maybe you want
to run the king
to some safety yeah on the other side
so it's definitely not over but yeah
once you play this
then yeah like everything crumbles
yeah right okay
so but definitely a better game yeah
yeah
he said it was a lot better yeah like
compared to that first game you were
eventually losing here right after move
20 the first game you were losing by
move like five
so yeah yeah okay so
i'll try to be more active with bishops
then next time i play maybe that'll
maybe that's the key
yeah um that'll lead to a more
comfortable position for sure
yeah um and even like
so i don't know how familiar you are
with like opening names but usually i
was gonna ask you
about that do you think that's important
for me to learn i don't really know
any yeah at your stage it's it's
probably just better to
start applying the principles and and
start getting a feel for
um for just playing more actively
but also more controlled and then later
on
it's probably probably makes more sense
to start learning specific openings
yeah um but like this is a position
you'll have you'll have so many times
because
right most people yeah in the same style
i feel like this is how all my games
start right
is there something like this you know
depending on if i'm white or black
exactly so like here i'd probably
recommend starting with this bishop move
because you're ready to castle right
away you're ready to play this move
um and uh the the game can branch out
from here in many ways
yeah but uh this would at least be the
starting point
rather than putting your pawn here
before bringing out your bishop right
so um okay cool
yeah uh i i think no i i think the
the approach you're taking with like
especially playing
playing a bunch of games at once and
then even like playing stronger players
this is how you'll
you'll learn a lot more yeah i'm gonna
keep playing him
and you know a couple other people or
whatever um
but also people might my sort of level
oh definitely yeah like you yeah you
definitely don't want to just focus on
playing players much better than you
and lose every single game that you play
i saw some of your wins too like you had
seemed like you had some nice wins
there was one i i i didn't there's this
the most recent game i played against it
might
be the one you have there against mw
plays trombone
oh i'm just checking i think it is
actually the most recent one
yeah i really wanted to go over that one
i'm sure actually
um because i got to a position
where i feel like i was playing as you
would say like passively
right um there i go with the bishop
again sort of getting it
but it's not necessarily stuck right
yet um not yet
but like in order to develop this bishop
you're gonna have to do this eventually
and then your bishop will be stuck
yeah well okay so anyway i think i was
like playing passively sort of like
trying to control the center
you know but this is still still very
solid yeah yeah and then i
just did not know what to do at a
certain point and i'll tell you
what point that is um like here
uh i know do you still have a plan
i did but then i i did something crazy
and it ended up working out and i have
no idea how it worked out
this is what oh yeah okay so yeah back a
couple moves
yeah this is where i did not know what
to do so
then i went for that thing that i
usually avoid
which is what you just showed g5 and you
did that
yeah this actually worked out
beautifully for you it did and i
it was kind of it was kind of an
accident funny
i wish i wish i like knew what to do in
the future if i wanted to do that again
but yeah i think he also he also made
some mistakes
so so i can show you
like after we analyze what happened i we
i can go back and i can show you
like at least from earlier uh a better
approach to use a similar strategy
that would be great because that's what
i was like i was thinking today as i was
playing this
um i was like oh man i wish i knew like
what i had done wrong in the first
10 moves you know in order to make
things more accessible for me
in order to open up better moves you
know right um and i was thinking about
asking you about this
game so i'm really glad that you that i
finished it before
this definitely did yeah um
now like one thing to address is that
you could potentially have the same
position
but with your bishop here imagine if you
just played your uh
that's really true yeah um
but let's okay let's see at least how
this unfolded because you played bishop
g5
i think this is the best move mm-hmm um
because you're you're pinning the knight
yeah
sometimes when you when you pin the
knight like this
one of the main ways for black to try
and defend is to get a bishop here
but the bishop's so out of play it can't
easily help defend on the king's side
right so black tried the next
best thing is to kick your bishop
um and you you played very well so you
played exactly what we talked
about i think when reviewing the first
game is you maintain the pin
and because black committed to castling
it's very very risky to like push the
pawns
on the king side like this yeah
and uh yeah you played exactly how i
would play here just knight takes
and um i know
like we talked about in general you
don't want to trade
uh like a knight or bishop for two pawns
i know
and that that's why i was like i that's
why i was
you know a couple moves before this i
was like i have no idea what to do this
is my only idea
basically so here actually you're not
even sacrificing
anything anything because in this
position you're you're attacking the
king
but you're also attacking the knight
twice yeah
because you're your queen and bishop are
lined up so you're guaranteed if you
wanted to
you could take the knight right away and
you're going to be on material
yeah but i didn't want to trade queens i
don't think that's true because you're
you're very close to just checkmating
black
do you think i could have checkmated
soon right here so here it's it's
difficult because
yeah um like black's controlling a lot
of key squares
in the territory like these squares are
controlled
the square is controlled and you don't
you really only have your queen
like your queen and bishop are the two
main attackers
and they're more focused against the
knights yeah um
so you you played the move that i would
play if i was trying to like win quickly
um i i think
this is a really interesting move and i
guess it
it did end up working out why did i do
that
i don't know why so i can explain it's a
good move
because you're you're trying to get the
rook involved oh yeah that is what i was
doing
and there's a name for this move i can
make a comment this is called a pawn
break
um it's simply when you move a pawn to
attack another pawn and offer a trait
okay and the great thing about pawn
breaks is they they can create open
files for
for a rook in this case for your your
rook on f1 which is a line with a knight
is that what he did or uh so he didn't
take he ended up attacking a queen
oh okay and then then here
oh you know what though
oh so i was just praising this move
this is actually a terrible terrible
move for
for a reason that's completely
irrelevant to the king's side yeah okay
tell me um it's funny because it's easy
to have tunnel vision where you're just
focused on the king side
um you have to so when you play this
move
you have to be aware of what you're
weakening i was blind to this too
upon first seeing this um
i guess the two squares that it was oh
the i mean the king opening right
he could just move he could just move
his knight and i'd be in check
yeah you're opening the diagonal yeah
what's what's the best knight move for
black
uh take the bishop
you can take the bishop yeah that looks
nice and this is actually double check
yeah um
is just to attack the queen
oh yeah of course again this is double
check you'd be forced here and you lose
your queen
so to take back everything i said this
is uh
it's not the move that you want to play
even though it's played with good
intention
i did not see that i'm glad he didn't
see it either
yeah yeah it's like uh it's just a
concept of tunnel vision where you like
sometimes you get too focused on one
area of the board
yeah you have to see the big picture so
so yeah in this case you should have
just taken and you're kind of giving up
on the hopes of checkmating early
yeah you win the minor piece back and
you're up to pawns here
yeah okay so um
but like these sort of situations are
usually what determine games
like one tactical oversight or one big
blunder where like one side loses a lot
of material and that can't
can't come back yeah
uh so here you're by the way yeah sorry
by the way it's it's nine i understand
if you have to go you know oh yeah um
no worries we can we can wrap this up uh
because it seemed like you got
oh actually this was yeah this is really
crazy yeah what did i do
again i remember it being like i kind of
walked into things in the moment like i
didn't really plan much
yeah your opponent found this move but
kind of a little bit too late
yeah and
yeah this this sort of situation we
could probably spend hours
like trying to understand the
intricacies um
but okay you did what you had to do you
got out of check you kept checking the
king
oh this is a great move
yeah this is actually very nicely played
it's a weird position because black's
attacking you but you're still trying to
attack the king
yeah and this was a bad move on multiple
levels first of all you can just take
and you're look supporting
oh yeah but you found the best move here
to check
and unleash your rook so you win the
queen for free
i think yeah i kind of and then you won
the night
and then you were winning um
so it wasn't the cleanest
approach from both sides because right
uh
first of all you you could have like
just been winning you gave black an
opportunity the opportunity was missed
yeah it was a big mess and eventually
you came out on top
um yeah yeah he was really mad at me
uh yeah this happens in chess where like
sometimes
right it comes down to who makes a
second to last mistake
right right and then who makes the last
mistake
so i can give you one plan in the future
which stems from this opening
sure let's imagine let's imagine you
play the best move
mm-hmm or the most active move yeah
black copies you
you play d3 black castles
now you can castle right away um
the the main point the the main
kind of strategy i just want to show you
is
the combination of this move and this
move
oh yeah if you can get both of these
moves in
after black's committed to castling it
can be very very powerful
imagine black just continues or okay so
let's imagine you play this right away
and black continues with this move
black's already in in big kind of
trouble here
because you're you're pressuring the
knight the knight's pinned
and it's so it's really not easy for
black to uh
to defend the knight with something else
yeah
um and this this gives me nostalgia
because i
i used to play this like all the time
when i was a kid like this
this combination set up yeah and i have
a lot of games
this person in particular definitely
would have played
pawn h6 if i did the bishop move
which would kind of not which would kind
of
debunk this this formation right yeah so
if they play h6 in this position
what you can do you can exploit the fat
this pawn it's defending too many things
at once
is what we call overworked you can take
the knight first
and then now this pawn's not defended
you take back
oh wow and you you win a pawn
and you uh you attack the rook and
you're having a very nice attack
yeah king side if we go even further
here
um i've shown like this exact game to uh
uh to students before where um
like the the play just continues where
the best move for white is knight h4
and then your goal is to get the queen
here this is a mating square
oh if you imagine black plays some
so it's hard to do because you you can't
move to g4 right away
right let's imagine black plays
i'll just show you one example line
black plays this
you can play knight f5 and now you're
clearing the way or you're kind of
blocking the
attack and if takes and this is force
mate
oh wow so wow
it's incredible like how quickly black's
position can crumble
yeah yeah um and it really starts with
the combination of your your bishop and
knight
wow that's that's really awesome so all
this is
saved right so i can go back and look at
this so this is all saved yeah
it's a sub variation um
so i can
i can make a new chapter and we can just
replay this
so chapter five i just call this opening
suggestion
i'll actually i'll call this um this is
italian opening
is it really yes oh wow now
there's different kind of different
branches of the italian but this is one
one example where we just follow
of everything everything i showed
um just replaying the game so it's
easier for you to look back on
uh knight h4 here
and yeah it's really just about
attacking with everything that you have
yeah oh that's really cool
i hope i get to do that one day yeah
yeah it's it's a very common
thing that players can stumble into
especially like around
around your level because they're
they're usually just focused on
unfollowing principles and they're not
aware of the danger
of yeah especially this this idea
but i mean if he wants to i guess he
can't
trade i was going to say if he wants to
trade knights but he can't because
he's pinned yeah right if he tries to
unpin himself like let's say
let's say the queen moves away from
being unpinned
and you can just take and this structure
again is really bad
and light can still land here and
there's a lot of weaknesses in black's
position
yeah very cool
so yeah this is maybe the start of uh of
some of your
uh i guess opening preparation but
yeah some ideas in the middle game
yeah i mean i think that just like
you're saying like just
freeing the bishops up will will really
help the future of the game because i
mean
um in the one with with uh with matt the
trump
mw plays trombone i think my bishop was
it it was a still
like kind of trapped wasn't it in a
certain way
i i think all the games that we looked
at yeah
your bishop was trapped in one way like
you played
oh we're still looking at this oh no so
yeah this i'm just going between
chapters here
but yeah this game this game um you
played d3
other game you played bishop d7 so
yeah like this doesn't only apply to
bishops this applies to
just all your pieces if you find just
more kind of
energetic squares you'll you'll enjoy
the position a lot more
it leads to more more opportunities as
well uh-huh
really cool okay um
i'll definitely i'll definitely try to
do that this week in one of my
18 games